antes de ser ejemplos usando la ley de
snl que esencialmente son problemas de
matemáticas lo que vamos a hacer en este
vídeo es tener una comprensión intuitiva
de por qué este popote o pajilla luce
como doblado en esta imagen para hacer
esto permítanme dibujar una versión
simplificada de esto mismo aquí voy a
hacer un dibujo de perfil de este vaso
más o menos así
el vaso
aquí va a estar
el popote o la pajilla
más o menos así
derechito estoy dibujando al popote como
realmente está no lo estoy dibujando
como se ve en esta imagen
que solamente está doblado aquí en la
parte de afuera
este popote está en un líquido que es
agua
lo que quiere explicar es porque cuando
vemos esta foto del popote en el agua
aquí en la superficie en esta parte el
popote luce como si estuviera doblado o
torcido y todo esto viene de la
refracción de la luz en esta sección del
popote que está cambiando conforme pasa
de un medio a otro
sabemos por los índices de refracción
que la luz en la base del popote va a
viajar más lentamente que la que se
encuentra fuera del popote ya que este
índice de refracción es menor o sea la
luz va aquí más rápido
más
rápido
la luz que está que pasa por el agua va
a ir más lento
pensemos en lo que ocurre aquí voy a
dibujar dos rayos que salen a partir de
la base del popote
uno de ellos lo voy a dibujar va a salir
de aquí bueno de hecho lo voy a dejar en
otro color va a salir de aquí y va a ir
en una dirección arbitraria vamos a
imaginar que sale hacia acá cuando éste
pasa de un medio más lento a uno más
rápido que le va a ocurrir viendo la
inclinación del rayo vemos que en el
lado izquierdo va a llegar al aire antes
que el lado derecho y aquí estoy usando
la analogía del auto las llantas entre
comillas del lado izquierdo si yo dijera
dibujaremos así van a estar en el aire
antes que el as del lado derecho por lo
que van a comenzar a ir con más
velocidad y al hacer esto mientras éstas
van más lentas va a cambiar su dirección
de manera que ahora la dirección que va
a tener la luz
un poco torcida hacia la derecha ahora
permítanme dibujar otro rayo que va a
salir exactamente de este mismo punto
pero que va a tener otra dirección una
dirección más o menos así
y que al momento de salir va a torcerse
también a la derecha
si el ojo de alguien estuviera aquí
este es
de una persona sus pestañas su pupila y
estuviera observando esa parte del
popote
imaginando que el ojo es suficientemente
grande para percibir estos dos rayos de
luz el cerebro va a percibir estos dos
rayos de luz como líneas rectas
es decir va a
procesadas el cerebro que este rayo en
lugar de haber venido torcido va a venir
una parte
derecha y este otro rayo
va a venir derecho
de manera que para la mente para el
cerebro
este punto de acá donde se intersectan
estos dos
rayos de luz
en este punto de acá
y si seguimos haciendo esto para un
montón de puntos en el popote va a
parecer que esta base en lugar de estar
aquí en el fondo del vaso va a estar el
popote va a enfrentar estar así
así más o menos y es por eso que a
nuestro ojo oa nuestro cerebro
la imagen del popo te aparece torcida al
estar aquí en el agua y todo esto ocurre
gracias a la refracción del paso de la
luz de un medio a otro espero que hayan
encontrado esto bastante interesante y
en el siguiente vídeo haremos algunos
ejemplos usando ahora si la ley de snl
para familiarizarnos con las matemáticas